what is a bigger concern to you you've
been around you've researched a lot
you've read a lot and stuff that's pre
my era and pre my former generation
you've been you've been reading a lot of
stuff on what's going on done a lot of
research with your
48 books what do you see as the biggest
threat today
you know is it inflation is it taxes
is it media is it politicians is it
china what is the biggest threat today
that we're facing
that's hard to pick a biggest i i would
say
the biggest threat if it wasn't even on
your list
it's the fact that the population of the
world has been
denied information so that they are
incapable of making good decisions
there they look at the world through
their television screens or their
computer screens they think everything
they see in front of that little screen
or in that screen that's reality
they can look out the window and see
that it's raining but if it says on the
radio
that the sun is shining they'll say oh
this it's a sunny day today
and i think that's the scariest thing
because as long
as the humans in this planet
can be programmed and passively accept a
condition where they accept authority
without question there is no hope for
mankind
because authorities sooner or later will
figure out
how to dominate their minds and control
them
in every way possible
it's a pretty deep answer right there um
and what's the price of that what is the
price of that long term
well the price of that is that we cease
being humans we see
being in the sense humans of our full
potential having
uh freedom of freedom of will
freedom of choice freedom of logic
to reach a decision or to question
freedom to
think even we become like robots
and of course that's what a lot of this
transhumanism really is all about
is to convert the present state of
affairs into two classes of humans one
are the ruling
elite who will remain pretty much as
humans always have been but maybe
genetically selected to choose only the
best and the highest intellects
but the rest of us to be gradually
dumbed down chemically
electromagnetically and through
information
uh starvation into robots that's the
that's the penalty
that's i think and i shouldn't say i
think i know that's where we're headed
because the people that are doing it
brag about it they talk about it they've
written books on it
they think how wonderful it's going to
be and uh i
i first i thought well that's that's
really weird this will never happen
but now i see ai developing and
and transhumanism and more artificial
things happening where people can
blend their bodies with mechanical
things and
i project that into the future and i'm
thinking oh my gosh maybe this is really
going to be that way after all
uh you know you you'll see the
opposition
uh those who uh oppose capitalism
they'll go and say well karl marx was a
noble man because
you know he he felt the capitalist is so
competitive
he's so hard working he's so ambitious
to seek more money and greed that he's
eventually going to create so much
wealth and not go out there fishing with
his dad
fishing with his kids and spend that
quality time with his
family and at the same time if
advancement goes at the level that it
does
eventually it's going to destroy itself
and implode
what do you say to that part of the
argument because
you're a capitalist yourself your
pro-capitalism your pro-freedom your
pro-choice you know pro-freedom of
thinking your
you know all of that but at the same
time you can you're concerned about the
advancement and the levels we're going
with ai
are we advancing and innovating a little
too fast or a little too quickly
well there's a couple of components to
that question about you know
the the general uh opinion of what marx
really taught
what you just said is has got nothing to
do with marxism but a lot of
students think it does they think well
mark's taught you know peace and
and uh cooperation and
non-competitiveness and so forth he did
not
i when somebody starts talking that way
i know that they have not read marks
they have read books telling them what
marx means but they have not read marks
if you read marx's books you'll find out
it's got nothing to do with that
it's all about crush your opposition
destroy your opposition
come to power take away the family take
away money
make make people uh obedient to their
rulers and masters in the name of the
greater good of society
he's he's he speaks nothing of the
things that the students think he
is it represents and you know he'll say
kill them all
and they make no bones about it not only
marx but lenin and stalin
all the good old boys and and uh you
know matze tung
all of those guys adolf hitler really
even though he's
a nazi he believes the same thing
there's no difference between what he
believed and what
marx and engels and and lenin were
teaching so
when when people talk that way i know
that they haven't read the books and the
and the manuals that the that have been
generated by these
totalitarians so having gotten that out
of the way i move on
to uh what was that i thought ai ai
what is your concern are we advancing
and innovating too quickly
well i i think we are i my only
challenge really is the word or the
phrase too quickly i don't think we
should move in that direction at all
i think it's i think it's whether it's
fast or slow
uh i mean whether you jump off the cliff
quickly or sort of slip off of it slowly
finally you're off the cliff
and you're through so i i don't think
it's a question of too quickly or not i
think it's a question of if we should be
doing it
or not and i really in my mind
i think it's it's contrary to what we
are i think if we were smart enough to
understand
who and what we are and where we fit in
this universe
we'll be very destructive first of all i
don't think it'll succeed
i really think that we can tinker with
the laws of nature only so far
until finally we'll blow it up and we
won't we'll cease to exist
we're not going to be these super
creatures at all
we will just cease to be able to
reproduce or that we'll kill each other
or something like that
that's what i i'm afraid will happen but
maybe maybe nature can be destroyed
maybe nature can be
uh converted into a death machine
so that everything just stops you know i
don't know either way it's a scenario i
don't think is a good thing
i don't want to think about that for
myself or my children or my
great-great-great-great grandchildren or
anybody
in in the future so i think if humans
really were
as smart as they'd like to think of
themselves they would stand back and say
you know
we don't tinker with the building blocks
of life we just don't tinker with them
because they're perfect as they
are they've lasted for hundreds of
thousands if not millions or trillions
of years
you can argue over the length of time
but they've they're pretty good
and they show a great deal of
intelligence and design and
functionality
that's far beyond anything that einstein
or any human could come up with why are
we tinkering with this thing
when we think well i think all we can do
is mess it up
[Music]